we'll be lucky min ash-shaytaan-i'r
rajeem bismillah hamdulillah Salam
alaykoum which is the greeting by now
you know peace be unto you welcome to
another episode of the detail all the
shows are exciting because we get to
learn about so many wonderful things but
this is an extra exciting episode one
because I have a very special guest and
and two because the topic it's a little
bit scary now but I find it it's a Iman
booster it's a faith booster we know
that we used our brain our intellect our
common sense
we took a scientific analytical approach
and came to this way of light because
it's the truth we didn't blindly come to
it we came to it through using our
reasoning and we study this book which
is the Quran the verbatim Word of God
which is full of facts not fiction facts
not fiction and anyone who takes as a
seer humble approach will come to the
same conclusion as over 1.5 billion
people have all across the world that
there's no way that this book can have
come from other than the creator of the
heavens and earth now in this book along
with talking about the purpose of life
why you been created while you're
hearing this what and where you're going
when you die it talks about the unseen
world that's right the paranormal the
jinn some people call it the ghost some
people call the spirits but what do we
as Muslims what do we believe and we're
going to get into the details of the
unseen world we come back don't go
nowhere
this is the danger
this is the thing
back here on the Dean show and this is
my share and shake of thousands all over
the world
this is shake dr. Willie boo SUNY who is
the vice president of Al Maghrib and
also the Imam of Clear Lake Islamic
Center did I make a mistake here now you
just gotta light it now I'm very excited
very excited because you were with us
before and I'll hum did allow you back
again hamdullah thank you for having me
thank you thank you very much how was
your family I know last time we were
together you said that you know your
family likes watching a Dean show yes
they love well this is for your family
we got a gift
Wow okay that's for your son how's he
doing kid he's doing very good very well
so you got some treats there okay cool I
like it good luck all right all right
says time is so short I took one of your
here I listened to one of your lectures
it was live and you were talking about
the six articles of faith and one of
them you talked about the unseen world
and it really the people that were
around me they were getting an Iman
boost because you were talking about the
jinn and this is something the
paranormal you know people say the UFO
ghosts and all that and they can't
pinpoint but it's LOM pinch points it
and we talked about the jinn the unseen
well can we start off in telling us what
is when we say unseen world and when we
mentioned jinn what is this okay smell
our handle artists are isola first of
all all praise due to Allah on his
praise and blessings and peace be upon
our Prophet Muhammad sallallaahu lemon
all the prophets and messengers and
their followers this is one of the
beautiful things about being Muslim that
basically you have an authentic source
that you can always go back to it and it
will teach you about things that you
might not arrive to Torah to get to know
it in your own and mostly sin related to
the unseen the next life this book and
the tradition of our Prophet Muhammad
saws on them it told us about another
creation of allah's creations who share
with us this earth we call them a genie
even there is a whole entire chapter in
the Quran talking about al jinn and so
many verses the Quran told us about the
jinn which has come from the world Jenna
what its meaning in an Arabic language
something invisible something remote
something move fast and al jinn is
basically accountable beings that Allah
created them from fire and they will
behold countable for their actions and
the day of judgment God will judge them
they were created before humans they
were created before humans they were an
earth and Allah told us the purpose of
the creation of us as humans and the
jinn as well he said were mihalick to
jean-noel insa illa li abuddin i have
not created humans and jinn for any
other purpose than to worship me to
worship me and Allah have sent to the
messengers have sent to them books and
basically there are nations like us
exactly and they share with us this
earth the only thing that Allah created
them in a way that they are invisible to
us as he said some hundreds or seven he
said in o yaara come who are Kabila whom
I threw that are all know that the Satan
and has basically kind they see you from
a position where you cannot see them so
we can't we can't see them but they can
see us
everything we're doing they can see you
yes these they see us but we cannot see
them yeah we cannot see them and in a
very rare cases very rare cases where
humans and jinn can interact with each
others or basically cross the lines and
that's where people maybe see things
which is very weird unusual and they
will be maybe it's it's Jin it's a jinn
so there are rare instances where people
cross that light they're not supposed to
cross the line no they're not supposed
to cross the line and that's why like
one of the great Muslims called
Shafi he said if anybody claimed that he
sees gin all the time
he's a liar and will not accept his
testimony and because Allah said that
the default rules that you don't see
them while they can see you that's why
the satan and basically his followers
and the jinn in general they can see us
but we can't see them and that's why
they can whisper to us they can
basically sometimes we're in very
incident rare incidents they can even
harm humans or terrify humans but Allah
created them to live normal life
basically to have their life they have
they don't bother themselves by our
existence exactly like when you have so
many things lived maybe in your house
they have their own life and they're
basically some insects some bacterias
viruses there is so many things loves
around are so many creations and they
live and share with us the earth but
they have their own system their own
life and we have our life as well can
you in English define it as genie
spirits
how would you in English translate the
word is there a way to do that you know
every language is impacted by its own
culture yeah one of the interesting
things about this word even the genie
word comes from the jinn which is Arabic
word because basically most of the
English speaker today are Christians in
Christianity the concept of jinn is not
something they are familiar with for
them there is angels and there is humans
basically there is those angels fallen
angels the one who disobey God like the
Satan for example that will be
originally an angel these evil souls or
these rubbles in heaven the rebel
against God and heavens and follow the
Satan there are demons for us we don't
see the Satan as an angel we believe
angels are creation that they were
created from light verses
the gin they were created from fire as
allah subhanallah said o hara paljah
enemy marriage amina i created the jinn
from smokeless fire also the satan
himself told god i'm not going to
prostrate myself before adam i was
created from fire and he was created
from the clay mud
so you see clearly here this is a big
difference between us and basically
their christian traditions that they
don't say that as one of the creation
but the jinn like the way we see it
versus you will see Jewish basically in
Judaism you will find trance of that
believe of jinn that also some suggested
according to passages and their book
that were created from fire and air so
many modern may be group among modern
Jewish maybe they will not believe in
the existence of the jinn but originally
it is a doctrine that exists among
Jewish but it's not something you see it
in Christianity let's take a break there
and we'll be right back with more here
on the Deen show coming to the truth
requires two things it requires deep
thinking that you've already done but it
requires another step and that's courage
if you have the truth but you don't have
courage you won't stand up for the truth
and that's as good as standing up for
falsehood I would say this thing that
you're just told thing it's not in the
scripture and they would say a marginal
note added by scribe yeah okay we know
that and I'd be thinking if you know
this is not the Bible why are you
preaching it as if it's gospel truth
go
back here on the Dean show with my
special guest dr. walid Basu knee chef
tell us now we know that as I said
earlier in Islam correctly you're our
teacher that we used our brain we use
the common sense and it what's
intrinsically in us also to come to this
truth that there's only one God we
worship Him alone not his creation that
we believe and all the messengers of God
including Jesus Abraham Noah Moses they
all taught the same way of life Islam
complete and total submission to that
one guy and that's how you get peace so
now there are certain tenants of this
faith and one of them is to believe in
this unseen world now can we attribute
now when people they talk about the UFOs
unidentified flying objects they even
have this paranormal activity going on
in some of these they say haunted houses
they felt like a presence of something
something even by the graveyards can we
pinpoint it as Muslims that this is the
work because they have films based on a
true story
not fiction these are events and they
bring in like these you know
Ghostbusters to come in and they're
seeing this paranormal activity they
can't figure it out are these the jinn
yes very possible I saw some of these
you see the two injuries yes yeah I saw
some of these documentaries and I and
there's a lot of films even came lately
about exorcism and stuff like a lot of
them yeah and basically I think was
trying to say earlier yes maybe the
people don't believe in a creation of
two called Jin but they still believe in
Council of demon think possess humans or
can harm or bother or
urge or scare even people yes we do the
Prophet for example said that the jinn
among them who fly so some of these
unidentified object the flying it could
be the jinn that you see them flying you
come across them also we know about the
jinn that they take the change forms
they have the ability to change forms
they come in a shape of different
objects can come even a shape of humans
a shape of animals certain animals
so basically you might notice them or
see them and while they are on one of
these
forms that's very possible also we know
that among jinn who lives in houses and
we the known as at our honor where they
live in the house where they live in the
house so many times you might there is
nothing in your house we might hear
something or we feel something walking
or a presence of some if a certain
energy like around you but you don't see
it and this will be the jinn for us as
Muslim we know that this is normal
basically you live your life in there
not supposed to harm you they're not
supposed to bother you they have their
live and I have my life and for us
there's extra things which is the
Prophet Muhammad SAW seldom told us
there are so many supplications so many
basically prayers that we do as Muslim
in the morning and the night when we
enter our home and when we sight will be
protected from such a jinn because the
rule goes like this Allah said in the
Quran about the genders a whole tyre
chapter and coach in surat elgin an
ominous allah who nominated Ali
we could not party today among us the
righteous the good ones among us who's
not like that her nasty who like to harm
people I like what you see in humans I
saw them gangs of them are you know
something on the other side absolutely
ok among them the righteous the nice one
the good ones and and so forth and
basically there are different so you
might come across among one who really
would like to harm a person or or hurt
them or they've hate the righteous
people sometimes they try to harm them
and maximum amount of harm that they can
do they can possess and even can reach
to killing the person they can it can
reach to that level and and we have so
many incidents and an historical
incident that they did such thing yeah
now we know that look
God Almighty he's the most loving the
most merciful he forgives all sins but
if you die associating a partner with
the one who created you you die on that
you can still repent am I correct before
you die but if you die
there's what we call never shirk
associating partners we've got you ting
the Hellfire forever this correct
yeah this is basically the most
dangerous thing to do
yes Allah said if you Allah will never
forgive this sin which is to associate
other with him now my point here is
because we'll see again paranormal
things unexplained like a statue will
come and there'll be some tears from it
and you'll see like some sounds come out
of different idols and and people they
get fascinated with it or someone will
come and they'll say in the name of
Jesus or in the name of this person and
then the person is healed and can it be
that this is the jinn working in these
situations and deviating people that's
possible that's muscle some of these
unnormal thought I heard let me just add
I'm so sorry that I heard that sometimes
the jinn they can go into a person and
they might have a stiff arm or some and
then someone will pray in the name of
you know the creation of God which is
only supposed to pray to the Creator and
then the jinn comes out and a person is
like wow this really must be because of
who they supplicated in the name of
so-and-so say that I am a you're right
you're right I'll tell you something
historic its interests similar to this
in the time of the Prophet Muhammad yes
the people used to go to the idols that
they used to worship beside God and the
idol will talk to them can you imagine a
piece of rock talk yeah Ida was a talk
to them and they said Muhammad look
these idols are God they talking they
talking to us and the prophets are
solemn basically proof to them that this
is not God if even if they talk they
don't deserve to be God because this not
the Creator
there is no multiple gods and and
evident earth and and all these things
that God cannot be in the shape of human
God has the divine attribute does not an
object you move it wrong list another so
even if somebody claimed that this is I
call the name of whatever and was healed
does not prove that this is a true or
that human beings can be God because
again human beings cannot be defined
like human and it could be from the
shape on and his follow from the jinn
because one of this the Satan's go he
said to God our world deviate humans
I will deviate them in anyway past
that's his main mission his main
measures ghost rats why God in so many
times in the Quran said us he is your
enemy and take him as an enemy whoever
take him as an ally whoever will trust
him he will only basically be among the
losers that's the [ __ ] and the devil
said the Satan devil which is his one of
the jinn one of the Jim and he has so
many followers among the jinn themself
so he has tasks he sent people to do to
deceive people deviate people whisper to
people inspire people to do what is evil
and wrong so that's very possible some
of what you can what you see like you
think oh this is that means he's upon
the truth
you know what magicians use this through
across the history they did this with
Moses they were never upon the truth
Pharaoh was not upon the truth truth
cannot be recognized by these abnormal
things truth can be written as I said in
the beginning of the this episode is by
looking at the evidence looking using
your rationale why of analyzing the
truth and knowing that this is the Word
of God or not there is this worthy of
being God or not now we will also hear
about seances where people will come
together some some very prestigious
people they'll go to these seances and
they'll do some kind of Voodoo this that
and the other and they'll call upon and
they'll see like someone from the past
they'll see their grandfather or they'll
say that someone will speak they'll hear
a voice and then they end up worshiping
what they call spirits yeah something
that now can be related back to the time
absolutely that's the gym because the
souls but after it will be taken it will
not be just left to room fairly so
that's the jinn and one of the things
that the Satan has one of his tasks that
he appointed for each and every human
one jinn to be in charge of basically
deceiving that humans and and working on
him and inspiring him to do what is evil
Amba and that knows that person very
well so you might come to you in the
shape of your father who passed away or
something out of your actual father
absolutely and he won
and he comes like that and he stalks you
if you see so this is very very possible
that's very possible and basically in
this case again you will see that this
is not the way I recognize the truth
let's hold down we'll be right back with
more Andy Dean show that he's alone
running this universe that he doesn't
become born because he's died he doesn't
eat go to the bathroom this is not God
yeah it doesn't make sense
who was Jesus worshipers this is
recorded in the Gospels despite all of
the other issues about the Gospels we
put those aside with the Saints
mentioned there with Jesus
back here on the Dean show and we're
talking about the unseen world that Jim
and we talked about people having
seances people seeing maybe their
grandfather from before or their uncle
father and then the Djinn you know
telling them giving them some kind of
power doing Spade can they do favors for
people like you know get them thing
information like the people who do like
the the you know the Ouija ball or
what's that the the crystal ball they
come in and they tell you certain things
and you're blown away again the Djinn I
have a real sister came to me and she
said she has this she said since I
became 13 years old I was gifted I have
the ability to read cards yeah and I can
tell you some about your future I don't
know something I said how's that started
she said I went to a person who's known
of things like this he said he stripped
me completely he put me in a bed I was
13 years old 14 years old at that time
and he covered me with the sheet and he
started doing some weird prayers and you
know put spell on me and after that I
was not normal for a while island after
that I was gifted that's what she called
and she said I used to tell the teachers
and the people in school about things
related to their live their homes what's
gonna happen to them sometimes correct
sometimes not then she said I became
Muslim later on and the moment I became
Muslim she said this has became a very
strong struggle with me I always feel
this energy coming pressing me and I I
had very hard time headache like voices
in my head and stuff like that and she
asked for my help and advice and well
interesting saying asking how would you
you said gifted what that means she said
when I look at these cars
I will hear certain voices and my ear
and basically I will tell the person
based on the echo of what I heard to
that person what happened to them or
might happen to them in the future but
you've said even I was so called gifted
girl but I never lived happy life and my
point is that those who the jinn help
they never helped them and to give them
absolute power that's why in the history
humanity everyone used gin look at cross
the history every nation in the past who
used gin magicians they never ruled the
world they were not the richest people
in the world and and so forth so
basically even the gin offered to help
the enslaved that human they will not
just do it for favor or let them go free
we have a few more point we're going to
insha'Allah God won't have to do a
continuation to this apart do we just
open up it's like an introduction but
for the person that maybe might not you
know get to see part two should people a
be fearful of jinn ship and how could
people be protected from those evil jinn
harming them I'll tell you something
that jinn are afraid of us and prove
more than were afraid of them more yes
we are way stronger than gin we jinn are
very weak creation very weak he
basically you have a shape you have a
body they don't have that ability that
you have that you this is your earth
this is your place basically you more
dominating that there's no doubt about
that
that they fear us more than we fear them
that's one thing too the more you think
about them in a way yes you will be
scared because you don't see them you
also scare feeling that you don't see
but the moment you still looking at them
you know what they have their own word
like I have my word
like so many things live in my house so
many my backyard and this earth with us
we we don't know about them so don't
bother resolve about three no doubt that
reading the Quran prayer is us basically
is the best why and form of protection
for yourself and they cannot even come
closer to you I don't know if we have a
minute to share these something now yeah
please yeah I remember I was reading on
somebody who possessed with with jinn
and that's true story I just like a what
people would say as an exorcism yes and
I have I'm what I witnessed that myself
what happened tell us and one other
thing that happened basically after a
read on the person and he was cure and
his body was cure of that the moment we
walked out I heard lash on his back like
some
but he with a web hit him on his back
and he jump about two feets in front of
me I immediately run to this guy and
uncover his back and I see that mark and
his bad this guy with me for the last at
least 24 hours I was with him not now
you're saying individual you've never
been locked up in any psych ward or any
other no no okay and I saw that with my
own eyes
yeah on him and basically I saw how
angry they were at him because we free
his body from these that evil whatever
he called spirit or jail there's this
jinn and later on when he was basically
they come back to him and I read on him
and when I asked them did you the one
who head to him he said yes under this
very strange voice and he said why did
you do that he said I I I hate it I was
so angry and I said why he didn't hit me
or my friend Adam which is a person next
to me he said I wish but I cannot
because you have did your prayer to die
your morning prayer you've been saying
your other car that the supplication the
prayer that you do in the day and I and
I cannot even reach you I cannot harm me
it's not about me anybody like this me
or the other person with me but the more
you remember a lot the more you have
this faith with Allah you are protected
you're strong you're stronger than what
than anything else on in live this is
part of Islam the unseen world paradise
the Hellfire that delights if you obey
your Lord do the good things he wants
you to do you got paradise and the
Hellfire if now you want to live
according to your desire you disobey
your Lord there's the ramifications of
that the day of judgement this is part
of the unseen WA and unseen world of the
jinn you told us how we can be protected
obey the Creator obey the Creator pray
to Him
submit yourself to him and God said
indicate the shaitana kanava eva the
plotting of the shape on the harmless is
very weak and allah so allah said in
evangelist and a Kareem so God my
servant my soul you have no power over
them you just submit yourself to your
Lord be his servant and be a basic obey
him and he has no control over you he
cannot harm you neither him or anyone of
us fast the key being Allah servant
being his slave
protect us may Allah protect us thank
you and we look forward to doing another
episode on the jinn welcome all right
all right
and thank you for tuning in to another
episode of the Dean show that's the
unseen world of the jinn and you know
how to be protected you heard it you got
to obey your Lord do all the good things
he's told you to do and they're weak
then but now you make him strong by
being weak in your Deen weaken your
Islam weak in your submission to the one
who created you now you set yourself up
for problems don't have problems turn to
the one who's the source of all
happiness and peace the one who created
you and do all the wonderful things that
he told you do and you'll be protected
you'll be protected we'll see you next
time on part two of the jinn the unseen
world with dr. shake well Libra Sunni
here on the Deen show we'll see you then
peace no speech is better than to do
that was call people to allah and to do
the word no speech is better you know
nothing is better than that is it true
that if one person I'm the Allah giving
you an ability to guide someone for the
lost permission the creator's permission
that is better than everything in this
world but in the whole world and
everything that's in it in another
narration it's better than the best of
wealth but if we really felt that Eddy
would we not be giving out getting down
and this is something that we encourage
all the MSAs all the dowel organizations
the mustards forget this we want to pray
more we give these to the non buses for
free for free for free we want our
brothers in Manatee
bismillah alhamdulillah Salam alaikum
peace be unto you welcome to another
episode of the Deen show we're gonna be
continuing on talking this week about
the unseen world the jinn the jinn we
know that Islam is something rational is
logical everything in there just makes
good ol common sense has answers to all
your problems solutions for everything
this week we're going to be talking
about something that we believe in this
unseen world we did a part one you can
go to the Deen show calm the
vice-president who's with us today of
the L motive Institute he's the Imam of
the Clear Lake Islamic center dr. Sheikh
Walid Basu knee he's going to continue
answering some of the questions we have
about the jinn the unseen world that
surround us they see us we don't see
them we want to know some of their
tricks we want to know how they live how
they eat what you know the communities
they live in and this is something
that's going to help to strengthen us so
we could be protected and so we can be
and continue doing God's will
so we don't fall to the tricks in the
traps of Shaytan and we'll be right back
with dr. shake Willie busoni don't go
nowhere
this is the thing
this is the danger this is the thing
assalamu alaikum point against Allah
how are you chef pretty good pretty good
from Dell we're gonna continue on
talking about the unseen world at the
gym people go to the den show.com you
have your own private section there and
they can see part one of the show we did
about the gin now I want to get into us
a very very interesting topic and we
know that you know 90% of the world they
believe what's already intrinsic in
themselves the belief in a create tour
now if you believe in a crate tour you
also you know you believe what he told
us about the shakedown the devil who's
out there and you mentioned earlier show
his mission is to mislead us in many
different ways so we want to talk now
the relation between when we say
shakedown ok the devil and then this
unseen world of the dent Jim are these
the same or are they different they want
of a like please continue to hear smilla
the satan some muslim scholars believe
that he is the father of algin like Adam
is the father of all humans and they
said the Satan is the father of all jinn
and they said the father of the jinn and
the father of human they had this
conflict in heaven
basically when Allah order the Satan to
prostrate himself before Adam and one of
the people who believed in that there
will be great scars name is Surya been
tamiya rahim allah and others and they
said that since allah said he as he can
see you him and his offsprings so
basically he referred to all the jinn as
his children his children that's why
they said he's the father of the jinn
and I lost my son knows best but we know
some some stuff about this creation
which is the devil first of all the
devil was a jinn because very clearly he
said about himself that he was created
from fire Allah Subhan Allah said in the
Quran so little cow ELISA can I mean al
jinn Mufasa khan amir alhabi
the satan was one of the jinn but
originally he was not evil he was not an
evil creation he was a very righteous
jinn worship God submitted himself to
the Lord and
he was even raised to the level of
angels that's why he was with the Angels
when God told the angel prostrated
himself before Adam but his arrogance
led him to reject the truth to reject
the order of Allah and that's why anyone
who reject the faith out of arrogance
feeling that I'm too big to submit to
the Lord he just basically following the
footstep of the Satan this Satan is so
arrogant the titre even to copy God like
God have basically appointed for every
human angels to protect them to inspire
them to good so what the Satan did he
look at his followers and his some of
his children who follow his footsteps
and he appointed for every human one of
his followers to inspire them to do bad
also the prophets of Sodom told us that
Allah told us in the Quran that allows
thrown above water it's not this water
on this earth somewhere up in the
heavens but the Satan's went down to
earth and he put his uh his throne on a
water and it's very interesting there is
a hadith says water but there is another
narration says on the sea and in Arabic
language the water map and sea has
completely different meanings in Arabic
language when he said see it means not a
fresh water so that means his throne
where he said where his kingdom
basically is and somewhere in a salt
water not a fresh water not a rivers
someone somewhere in oceans or one of
the seas and basically he send his
followers he said basically those who
listened to him and and worship Him
instead of God to put evil tasks on
earth evil tuscan-inspired people to
kill to fernika to steal whatever evil
tasks that they to an earth we know also
a little bit about the so he is the
father of the genie but or one of the
jinn let's say according to some of his
cows as well those gin among them the
worshipers the righteous and
them the evil on the band you have some
Muslim Gino's absolutely and you have
and from every religion from every group
that's why when when the al-assad in the
Quran
well Solana la cara foraminal Jin we
have led some of the jinn listened to
you Muhammad when you reciting the Quran
so they went back to their people they
said this is sounds very similar to what
Moses used to recite the Torah so
basically the chose also among them
there have knowledge of the Torah and
the Bible and the David songs and so on
so because they were existence before
Adam so they have met and known and seen
all these prophets and all these
messengers basically among them the good
and the righteous among them the bad and
the one who basically like to harm
others like to hurt others they
intermarry they have childrens Allah
told us that they have children they die
like humans they die a Djinn died
absolutely like us the Prophet SAW
solemn used to supplicate to Lord as if
you are the most you are the living one
who never died and humans and jinn died
did the jinn die when the human being
dies who they're not necessarily but
their lifespan is similar to our
lifespan yes they died exactly like us
they live and did they die also what we
know about them they basically as I said
the intermarried and they eat they eat
also and they eat and they drink how
they eat how they drink how they consume
this we don't know exactly like you will
someone was telling me how they eat if
the if you can't see them I said you
know what there's a lot of things feed
on things and you don't know how they
consume is it by eating it digesting it
sucking the nutrition of it we really
don't know the fly eats off your food
doesn't it when it comes yeah you know
the food doesn't disappear absolutely
yeah exactly
so also we know about them that the
Prophet SAW solemn said that they eat
with their left hand and they basically
give and take with their left hand not
with the right hand
also we told that
certain animals can see them like dogs
they can see the gym and they can notice
them the dogs yes he can see them also
one of the thing that we know about the
the Djinn in general or that they live
from this earth and Allah said that they
will live in this earth they will die in
this earth they would resurrect in this
earth and they will be judged on this
earth also we know that the jinn will be
judge exactly like us some of them will
go to heaven so I'm gonna go to Hellfire
those who did not worship God will go to
Hellfire
also we know that God send them
messengers and books through the history
to guide them exactly like the same
thing he did to us as humans as humans
one time the Prophet SAW sometimes saw a
man sitting on there in a position where
half of his body in the shade and half
was but in the Sun he said this is how
the shape unlike to sit how this don't
like to say one thing we know about
their look that this that the kafir
among them the disbelievers among them
they look so ugly that's why Allah said
the trees of the day of the hell the
fruit of it looks like the devil's looks
like the faces of devil nobody saw the
face of the devil but humans by nature
know it's ugly no it's scary we know
that he has horns and like a lot of
people throw the devil at the horn yes
we know that he has also horns the
process on said that that he has horns
and we know that the Satan also like to
order his followers to prostrate before
him during the sunset time and sunrise
done it that's why we Muslim we don't
pray at that particular moment the
sunset and the Sun that rise this is
some one thing that we know about to
them don't lose your place shape their
signal we gotta go to a break and we'll
continue on from there who come back
we'll right back here in a tea shop
all of the profits would have been
labeled Muslims because this essential
message was the same message submission
this is God talking to you how can I
stand behind the pulpit and Sunday
morning and preach a sermon that I knew
was at variance with the actual taproot
of Christianity
back here on the D show we talk
dr. shake will lead by SUNY we're
talking about the unseen world of the
jinn and how can someone how can we you
said that they're actually per their
week but are you more susceptible
because we here and again these are
based on true story incidents where
people get possessed by the jinn DS what
can you say evil spirits the yep the the
evil among the jinn yeah and then they
get possessed so what can a person do
and is a person more susceptible if he's
not doing the will of God of the crater
obeying him and his commands worshiping
him alone and doing all these things do
you set yourself up where now you be
make him stronger I just want to set a
rule before even if you don't mind I
answered this question whenever we talk
about the world of the unseen we have to
differentiate between two things that
when it comes to the unseen in general
yes there's a lot of things we can
comprehend yes but it doesn't mean
necessarily we can imagine yeah and this
is a big difference between imagining it
and comprehending it for example I
cannot imagine gravity yes
I cannot imagine infinite I don't mean
the car yeah okay
I cannot imagine so many things but I
still comprehend what what it is what it
means
so the world of jinn yes sometimes you
cannot imagine their existence and how
they live and how they possess and how
they do all this but I can understand
that comprehend that so a lot of people
because they cannot imagine it they
cannot visualize it they rush to the
night but that doesn't make any sense it
doesn't make any sense
so I just I want to make that
distinction is a very important point
yeah yeah you see that yeah
as for yes they are weak sometimes the
harm humans sometimes they possess them
even and basically I would like to say
that this is a very rare case and it's
not something even easy on them that's
basically because it's against the
nature of their life that's not so it is
restr rare and it's not supposed to
happen and it's basically getting out of
your way to do it so it's not something
the pleasant for them a pleasant for
them they then
not very yakking about doing things like
this yeah 30 rare case most I have seen
a lot of peak cases and in my life that
people come to me and said hey my son is
possessed my daughter or I am myself set
and I can tell you 90% of the cases are
not true not true but there is cases
which is absolutely true where there is
a possession
whereas houses are basically full of
jinn and they want dis houses for them
and they don't want anyone to share this
house have you ever walked in a house
like this in a situation yes I can you
share I've been once in a in a situation
like this where basically a lot of weird
things happen in this I was at that time
in in high school actually and we went
to that one of the houses very old house
very old house and we rented this place
and basically a lot of weird things
start happening doors opening closing
lights goes on and out by itself it's
another electricity problem it just not
it's not normal at all it's completely
numb and one of our friends start acting
very weird and basically sleeping all
the time and starts saying and doing
things very weird for example which is
impossible to be he's not capable of it
he will be sitting in the room with
someone and he will tell there is
someone now in the street so on so
person coming up and he gonna knock on
the door he someone's coming to the door
and he's saying hey someone's gonna not
gonna yeah you don't even see through
the wall and there is no any logical
possibility that this know this person
know that this person is coming it's
impossible and he would say this
person's come so this is very weird and
he will start using very weird languages
words that this person we know him for
years he's not familiar with this
languages at all
so basically when we start reading on
him and and stuff like that we found the
reaction was very severe very severe
weird weird voices coming out of em and
screaming and hitting and stuff like
that
so when finally were able to let that
evil spirit and I'm to talk he basically
said this is our house and we live here
and you guys have to leave this place so
I told him that's not right
I rented this place from the guy
upstairs who own this apartment and I
have a contract you know he can't this
is not right if you have a problem take
it upstairs but most I was sort of fled
and said I'm out of here you're like in
a dialog absolutely and I think that's
the best way if you ever been positioned
like this yeah so if you have a problem
take it upstairs with the guy
is he thought talking to the person
versus the present very completely
different different voice voice tone and
stuff like that yeah and hamdulillah we
were able to they sat out on a way that
he said he would leave his body but he
said you guys leave immediately
anyway it was one experience one of the
early experience I have seen one of the
things I remember a group of
psychiatrics
we had a debate in Bahrain with a group
of psychiatrics about the issue of
possession they denied and the reason
they denied because they denied the
existence of jinn yes so I said first of
all we cannot talk about possession if
it's possible or not if you don't
believe in their existence and if you
don't believe in their existence you
don't believe in what's in the Quran
I've got unstated clearly there is jinn
and in so many verses as for the
possession itself that person possessed
with jinn I said you cannot deny the
reality what you see with your own eyes
forget about debate over text I'll give
you one other thing I do whenever a case
like I had I will say because sometimes
they trick you even the person himself
the person himself he can act like he's
possessed
because psychological problem but I have
seen cases like this but one of the
thing I see if you really a jinn I said
I will put an object in the side in the
other side of the room like in the
corner of the room I said knock it down
like a bottle tissue box and if he knock
it down
that this is not human yes because there
is no way possible in a closed room no
air nothing and this is will be knocked
down like this yes accidentally over
it's impossible so I know that I'm
dealing here with that with the gin and
this happened several times several
times I remember even one time we did
this in a prison of I said contracts
himself you are doing this in front of
him he asked us to be involved to what
we call the the exorcism exorcism
economic and reading the Koran to get
the gin out out of the purse yes anyway
so when you have cases like this all
what you do is you read the Quran on the
person and you have a dialogue sometimes
you can when intellectually with the
person that's why I'm saying the Quran
have very strong power over them the the
scream they cannot take it because they
fill the power of the Quran over those
pallets so so different than humans
that's why I was telling you human are
worse than jinn you read the whole Quran
over someone he were like okay so
whatever but jinn you just read start
reading Allah Allah you know how you are
you they were screaming cannot take it
and I remember one of the jinn said I
don't believe in God to me he said I
don't believe in God I said you sure
about that he said yes I don't believe
in it I said okay then I said Allah who
he screams then I will say some poetry
in Arabic and he will be listening and I
told him what's the difference why are
you screaming when I read this lines in
Arabic and you are very normal and read
this lines in Arabic she said I don't
know I said you lie
you know what's burn you what's really
affect you is the verses of the Quran
it's the words of God and you knew it
don't tell me I don't believe I
hamdullah and finally he had met at he
admitted that there is a god there is a
lot there is exhaust and and so many
times even they accept Islam hamdulillah
and they will even leave the body of the
person but what I want to say there is a
lot of people also imagine things like
this and I have a lot of stories also
people claim that they have jinn or
possessed and there is nothing wrong
with the psychologically they are
basically effect
psychologically be going through trouble
hard time and the imagine that and they
they they acted like one
let's attribute it to Jim let's take a
break we'll be right back with more
Indonesia he born about 60 years ago in
former Yugoslavia
today's Bosnia after second world war
and imagine today you have one child
feel too much it's important that we
realize that Islam is a gift so we
believe that in the teachings of Jesus
what is left there is truthfully Amina
he's the but the truth has been mixed up
with paganism and with nature worship
and so Islam has given you a pure
straightforward way of approaching
monotheism
I Karen Edina Sean we're talking about
the jinda unseen world of the gin with
dr. shake Willy bassoon II tell us now
before we went to break you said these
are rare cases that a person will get
possessed by the Djinn but in cases that
people do and let's say they want to get
some therapy all right
now you'll hear weird things people out
there who tell them to do you know I've
heard this myself you know go get a
chicken and then they write some weird
stuff they give you some ambulance to
put out all these weird and bizarre
things is this and does it have anything
I'm sure you have no experience this
have anything to do with Islam and
what's the proper way to the proper
proper healing of getting this you know
okay first of all the best way to do
that is to read Quran is to call the
Adhan like in the house for example
there is presence of gin in it you read
the Quran in it the process of you read
certain Baqarah the gin will not enter
this house you would enter your house to
say bismillah you call the Adhan in this
house you start praying in this house
and another lost man to Allah will take
this away that's one thing if somebody
possessed you read the Quran in him and
you can read in your own self and they
no one person here it on him also until
Allah smart-aleck cure him so that's
that's one thing the second basically
also you can read in a water and you
consume this water and if somebody
possess what in the moment I give him
the water which is read Quran in it and
I blow on it he will throw up he would
never if he consumed it you're good I've
dariya good the bathroom so sweating it
will never settle in his body but the
more he do that the more he protect
himself from inside asks for the jinn
the jinn they don't like certain colors
sometimes they don't like certain smells
sometimes so some people by experience
they know these so they let that person
see these colors see these animals see
these with smell senses and that's
bother of the jinn and let them leave
the place leave the place and sometimes
it can be effective but anything
involved worshipping jinn or killing or
sacrificing or that logic and sacrifice
that's not allowed that's for have you
heard of somebody absolutely and this is
basically the gin useless trick to make
you commit the major the major sin that
ever a human can commit which is
basically to offered any form of worship
to other than God and basically to
humiliate the humans and to let them go
to that low level of being worshipper of
the devil or the demons one more thing I
want to say here sometimes with the
didn't possess humans they can make a
physical damage so treatment can be very
effective like in certain cases you
might somebody their psychiatrist will
prescribe certain medication for the
person and I believe it works very fine
for them because those children they
possess human they may cause mm achill
imbalance and brain and the medicine
will balance it out they might make a
physical damage to your hand and therapy
and basically operations some exercise
physical theory can return it back to
its normal the Jesus I possessing you
they did some of these it can cause
physical damage and this is can be fixed
through medicine through basically
therapy the modern size who is a Muslim
we don't deny or say they have nothing
to do with things like this actually can
be very helpful and basically we
hand-to-hand we work together so
anything that's weird something that
these these weird incantations something
that you know you you would repulse
usually like that's something where it's
a red light hold on I need to go check
up with a true Islamic scholar because
you got a lot of people dealing with
witchcraft and all that has nothing to
do with this absolutely that's
unacceptable unacceptable so the only
way is like you said reciting the Quran
the verbatim Word of God over this
person these other details or reciting
over the water and yes or or it's
basically a treatment prescribed by
physicians or psychiatrist that DC that
this is a form of treatment they
diagnose the problem and what we hear
the difference we feel we sometimes
believe that this problem could be
caused by jinn yeah
and that's where maybe some doctors and
I agree with us now you'll see a lot of
people who right away they say Oh IIIi
think I got the gin in me when you
evaluate their life you know they're not
submitting themselves completed to the
crater say the woman's not wearing hijab
you know she's partially praying you
know dressing promiscuous or the the boy
also going to nightclubs messing around
with the ladies we know in Salaam is
marriage and it is test-driving and then
they right away they feel like man I got
this gin in me or some can this be the
effects of this sin now more so ho that
see the dissent these sends the gin
doesn't mean possess humans it means
make them collapse I'm big you know then
inspire them to do about the gin will be
more happy to make you do all this sin
then possessing your body the gin will
be much more hardly to have you disobey
your disobey creator then just balling
or harming you yeah you know because he
harm you already by leading you to the
way that lead to the Hellfire so he's
happy that's the best thing he can do
that's the best thing right tell us
before we are a few more points before
we were almost out of time tell us you
know I remember listening to a story you
told us that there was one of this
person that he was putting blades in his
body right and then there was a 'muslim
happen to come in the room and just
recite I hate to curtsy yes and then he
wasn't able to do it and what can you
share the story with us yes the story
happened in dubayy some performance he
used to put like daggers in his body and
basically he said I put all these
daggers on my body and he used the
jinnee said all the observed the daggers
and people think that I put it on my
body I never did and in that day of
performing in Dubai and this young man
came in holding the miswak and his hand
and he started reciting I took courtesy
I can see it he said I can see him from
a distance the moment he he did that the
jinn run away and all the daggers went
straight to my body and I fall on the
stage I was taken to the hospital said
after a couple of months he said for two
years I have nothing in life but to harm
this person and to hurt him back I was
able to get his name where he
and every jinn that I can put my hand on
through my practices of magic and
dealing with jinn I used to send them to
him and every time they come back to me
said we couldn't touch this boy we
couldn't harm this boy and he said the
reason is always the same when I asked
them why they said this boy never missed
a lot
never missed the prayer never missed a
prayer that's the key being in
compliance with all the things that the
Creator told us to do and that main
important thing is the date so
production is a protection you know the
Prophet said prophet you hear John one
has addressed his people and he told
them the example of us humans with the
devil like the example of somebody his
enemy trying to capture him then he
enter into a castle would have very high
walls thick walls so the enemy were not
able to reach him he said this castle is
the remembrance of Allah it's the prayer
that the the person that do every day to
his Lord and this is the protection that
we as human needed to be protected from
all these devils and evils out there
just a couple more points couple more
points tell us if a person feels okay
now they really feel that they need to
have some rookie are done right that's
what it's called yes and they go to
someone a Imam or some you know person
that they feel alright he can help me
but this person is doing some some
things that you know the community is
saying yeah go see this man he makes the
lights go off he go he does this crazy
stuff is this also a red and that's a
red light anyway when I use an unknown
language like weird words are unknown
linked or somebody start putting like
citizen smoke and and like you dark
rooms and all the stuff and basically
ask you about your mother's name give me
a picture of someone that you know a
piece of cloth make a fire ask you to
kill animals or to sacrifice something
you sometimes eggs touching you and
stuff like anything like that this is
this is basically the honey this is
baloney yeah this is a person who
if we call him in Islam in Islam we call
him magician we can and anybody give you
basically a fortune tellers also we call
them we give you for example a charm to
hang it on you or to put it in your neck
or and around your kids for protection
that absolutely has nothing to do with
the slap the protection is very simple
pray your prayers make your supplication
than they in the morning every day ask a
lot to protect you and believe me that
Allah always with you was the most
merciful the most loving God Soprano it
down
you just gotta obey Him you got to do it
the wonderful things he's told us to do
and then we would be protected
absolutely thank you very much thank you
very much for being with us once again
may God Almighty the creator Allah
reward you in abundance thank you thank
you and there you have some great advice
be with allah be with the one who
created you worship him alone not his
creation established the prayer the
salaat five times a day and looked to
please your Lord by doing everything he
told you to do loving everything he
loves and hating everything that he
hates being complete come compliance
with his will with all the wonderful
things that he told us to do following
the example of the last and final
message sent to mankind of problem a
peace be upon him and spend your time
wisely stay away from bad company bad
people and just live a good life how
Allah told you to live it obeying him
and everything and you'll be okay and
this is what we need to be striving for
each and every day we'll see you next
time peace be unto you
merci on the smooth OBU Lord and submit
to him avoid the danger of the major
sins obey your Lord repent to him avoid
the danger of the major sins obey your
Lord and surrender to Him avoid the
danger of the major sins obey your Lord
submit to him mercy on us all the souls
avoid the footsteps of Shaitan
who's plotting scheme in 24/7 trickery
deception falsehood lies anything to
keep you in the firing line you have to
pray as if everything depends on
but you must work everything depends on
you that's my point you see the same and
I don't like that I don't like us
sitting here what are you waiting for
what are we waiting for right now what
are you waiting for all these people
that come to this law what are you
waiting for what are we waiting for
right now when they're gonna come
they're gonna come along and bring these
people lots of Palawan
put in our hand the ability to do your
job
I am Not Afraid I am not afraid to stand
alone if you live by my side I am not
afraid to stand alone I am NOT a to
stand alone if you live by my side I am
not afraid to stand alone I am not
afraid to stand alone I am not afraid